[Applaudissements]
non moi puisque toi
non moi plus que toi les 9,1 dans l'ue
non c'est toi d'abord toi d'abord à les
mises aux bisous mais roy maman voilà je
fais aussi des méthodes daniel commence
à ce que tu reviens cette année en tnt
c'est pour l'argent
ah non ben c'est pour les brooklyn en
boîte de nuit
non non dis moi c'est pourquoi alors ah
non moi je suis revenu pour kane zach
estaca yves ballot alors on est fatigué
je suis mort sans rire entre répondre à
mes fans à l'international mais prime
time à vis des animateurs le succès tu
connais pas ça mais décider moi j'ai un
truc infaillible pour moi en bien du
compte les moutons
maintenant je composais que les femmes
alors si tu as besoin de quoi que ce
soit je m'appelle
soit je m'appelle mais alors si tu as
besoin de quoi que ce soit tu appelles
gibert d'agen
cette saison j'ai deux objectifs pécho
des meufs et pêchu des scoops a pas de
risques créés sont des scoops c'est
mieux ce jour je ne suis pas le meilleur
pour les compliments mais franchement tu
content que tu aurais dans tpm paix la
joie ton look ton intelligente et un
photon charisme en vrai qu'il m'a manqué
c'est vrai mais pas du tout pour faire
oublier que tu avais déjà fait des pmp
s'est dit qu'est ce que tu me le cid de
corneille un corner j'adore sembla que
tu connais pas bien sûr que je connais à
l'arrivée chaque jeu valeur dernier à la
papa chapeau qu'il avait craint de 15
donc voilà ça c'est une petite photo de
vacances oignons c'est assez trop bien
oui un homme alors ça c'est quand je
naviguais sur méditerranée c'était la
folie à ces super deux soeurs du bateau
un homme est ma chérie c'est pas un
bateau c'est un yacht away et comment tu
écris yachts a nommé tu as raison c'est
un bateau et max noël c'est dire tu
étais vraiment très bon dans l'émission
non h toujours vraiment j'étais bluffé
ah bah merci super sympa mais je n'étais
pas là hier c'est ce que je dis td
parfait benoit scheen croisée de thierry
moreau tu vas à recueillir il a pris
cher pendant les vacances mais du
caravage saison mais il est bon mais la
regarde
incroyable incroyable mais c'est pas
thierry moreau c'est daniel moreau salut
à thé resplendissante daniela
quand est-ce qu'elle va accueillir celle
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]